this is a production of cornell
university
welcome everyone my name is kirsten
kurtz
i am a soil scientist at cornell
university
so as penny said part of that role is
managing
health laboratory i'm also a graduate
student at cornell
in the department of natural resources
and i am known for my soil painting work
i included one of my soil paintings here
on the screen
um my undergrad is in fine art and i
hold a lot of interest in communication
so this is part of what i do i do have
contact information up here you should
feel free to reach out to me directly
if you would like to
all right so i want to start by talking
about
um why i love soil and why soil is so
important
to me it's important to understand that
95
of the world's food comes from soil so
i'm often asked if
hydroponics or something like that could
replace this and the short answer is no
you basically just need to think about
all the grains that we eat
the meat and dairy that many of us
subside on and you can see that this
isn't a realistic
solution and of this soil we've lost
a third according to the fao of the
arable soil on the planet
along with that we've lost 50 to 70 of
the soil carbon stock
i'm sure you guys have heard a lot about
soil carbon i'm going to talk about soil
carbon quite a bit today
um we know that soil stores more carbon
than the atmosphere and plant life
combined
so it's very important that we hold as
much soil as possible
carbon in that soil is possible we also
know that without change and by that i
mean
without a move to a more sustainable
agricultural system
we've got about 60 harvests
all right so i know that this is really
depressing
but i really need to kind of explain why
i care so much about soil and why i
think that this is such an important
thing to study
and to work on the improvement of
so i'm going to talk a little bit about
some um kind of basics and so
soil science just to build a foundation
for the talks that i'm going to give
about our lab
so one of the most important things
about soil is aggregates
so aggregates are those little crumbs of
soil that you can see in a healthy soil
system
you can see some pictures here on the
screen being held by the hand
and those little aggregates are held
togeth together
by root and worm exodus which is
basically the slime
that comes off of roots and comes off of
worms
and that helps to hold those aggregates
together
and a lot of the life of the soil
happens within the aggregates
so that's part of the reason why they're
so important
and then around those aggregates is
space which is also incredibly important
because that's where the water
and the gases are moving through the
system
it's very important to not have a
compacted system
because we know that this life is
primarily living inside the aggregates
and so much of the nutrient movement the
water movement and those things are
controlled by that space
so we can see here that soil is about
half solid
and about half water and gases
which is really important for
understanding the way that we look at
soil health
um so many of you may have heard it's
kind of a clich
day within soil science at this point
but it's true
that there are more organisms in a
teaspoon of soil than there are people
on the planet
by this i'm talking about a healthy soil
but and
of those organisms we really are just
starting to
um scratch the surface and understand
what these different
organisms do and when i'm talking about
soil organisms
i'm talking about microbes bacteria and
fungi
and these hold a lot of really important
roles
within the soil system and within soil
health
including that they decompose organic
matter
and through that they're increasing the
nutrient availability
and storage within your soil
we also know that having a healthy
microbial community helps to protect
your plants against pathogens
so your plant is more likely to be able
to
push through maybe a disease or
something like that if it's in a
healthy system and we also know that a
healthy soil has increased
aggregation and poor space which is
really what i was talking about
on that previous slide
all right so organic matter is obviously
a really
important part of soil health um
and one of the things that i think is
important to understand about organic
matter
is that all organic matter is not the
same
so we say in soil science the living the
dead
and the very dead right and those are
all um different properties of these
organic matters
so what i'm talking about is the living
would be um compost
the actual biomass of the bodies of the
microbes themselves
it's things organic matter that can be
quickly cycled through the system
when i'm talking about the dead i'm
talking about a more stable organic
matter
i'm going to talk a lot about this
active organic matter which is what we
call the dead organic matter today
we measure that in many different ways
and then of course there's also the very
dead
which um is also referred to as humus
and this is basically that really
carbonaceous
material in your soil that's very very
stable
and it's hard to lose so organic matter
is typically
one to six percent of a total soil mass
i know
um some of you guys are landscapers or
have these um botanic gardens things
like that
you might see way higher levels of
organic matter in those types of
systems i'm really talking at least with
this slide store about more of a
corn soy rotation typical ag system
um and the soil organic matter has
really important functions within the
soil
most importantly in my opinion would be
the nutrient storage
as well as improving that soil structure
and decreasing erosion so having good
organic matter levels in your soil is
actually going to help
make your aggregates that i showed you a
couple slides ago
more stable
all right so with this i'm going to move
into soil health
so the nrcs defines soil health as the
continued capacity of soil
to function as a vital living ecosystem
that sustains plants animals and humans
um this sustaining i feel is the really
key part of this definition as well as
the vital living ecosystem
it took a long time for soil scientists
to understand that soil
is indeed a living ecosystem
and when people talk about soil health
what they're really talking about
is looking at the chemical aspects of
soil nutrients ph
things that everyone's very familiar
with along with the biological
and the physical aspects of soil and we
look at them together in a holistic way
so talking about biological aspects
that's basically going to be biota the
life
of the soil carbon organic matter
physical is going to be that structure
of the soil
and the texture
all right so i wanted to give you guys
just a very brief overview of kind of
who we
are at the cornell soil health lab um we
developed the cash test
which some of you may have heard of um
we opened this lab in 2007
it was the first soil health test in the
world to my knowledge
at this point we've tested over 10 000
samples
and we do accept samples from around the
world
and we use that information to not only
report to our clients what their results
are of course
but also to build this gigantic global
soil health database
and this helps us to understand where
your results for instance fall in
against
all of the other results that we've
received in our lab
we also do a lot of work in research
outreach and education we've developed
many of the tests ourselves
and we also go and talk all over the
place including this talk today to try
to
expand the knowledge and interest in
soil health
so i've included our website here we
have a
really gigantic website with just masses
of information but worth noting
is that our book is there for a free
download
we also have fact sheets which really
really simplify these concepts
that could be useful for you or the
people that you work with
so when we wanted to um develop
the cornell soil health test and i
should mention this whole project was
led by harold van ness a professor at
cornell and
former president of the soil science
society of america
among other among other interesting and
impressive
qualities he basically was looking for
things that were
very sensitive to management this is one
of the
key things about the way that we look at
soil health so we're able to
differentiate for instance the
difference between a plow till field
and a no-till field through these
different tests so it had to be
sensitive to management
it also needed to be affordable
and easy to replicate so
we looked at i believe originally 64
different soil
health properties and then we dispelled
it down
to this list which um i will say
is always kind of changing for instance
this year we added total carbon total
nitrogen
um additionally in the biological
aspects and you can see we look at a lot
of biological aspects in our lab we look
at organic matter we look at soil
protein
we look at soil respiration and we look
at active carbon
um on the physical aspect we're looking
at texture
we're looking at aggregate stability and
we're looking at
surface and subsurface hardness or
compaction
and then in the chemical we're looking
at ph and your major and minor nutrients
it's useful to think about the chemical
aspect of our testing
is really similar to what you would get
from a typical soil test that you could
get from pretty much anywhere
would be that chemical aspect plus
organic matter
typically
all right so it's really important to
have a
question before you sample your soil
um we always recommend that you take two
samples this isn't because we're trying
to make money we're
not for profit and we're very busy um
this
isn't the goal here the goal is that we
can tell you so much more and you can
understand so much more about your soil
with this concept which we call
comparison sampling
so in this case you can see this sort of
little um
map or whatever you want to call it with
the zone x and the zone y
and we're looking at the differences
between no-till and plough till
now you'll see that there's kind of this
w shape that goes across the field
this is um the way that we recommend
sampling
and we also recommend that you would
avoid anything that's not representative
of your field so in this case we have a
low spot
and we're avoiding that but you could
also think you know look across your
area and if you have a really really
good yield
and poor yield you want to sample that
mid-range yield
right so that you can really get an
honest
answer about what you're looking at
within your soil
anyway each one of these points what we
do is we take a sub sample
at the end of taking all these
subsamples we mix them
very well and then we pull out a
composite sample that gets sent to our
lab
we also take penetrometer readings at
each point that we sample
and i'll talk about what that means a
little bit later
um but yeah i do have to just kind of
make a plug for having a question
and not just sending in one sample
another way to use this would be to look
at something that's never been managed
versus something that has been managed
there's a lot of different questions you
could ask with this approach all right
so i'm gonna begin by talking about our
biological indicators
uh quite simply the life of the soil and
i have them
listed again here and i also just have
to give a shout out to my favorite soil
microbe which is the tardigrade which is
all the way at the bottom on the left
this is also known as a water bear and
what's so amazing about this creature
is it can actually be frozen for
thousands of years
thaw out and it's totally fine it can
survive in space
it can survive um radiation
it's really amazing and it's just one
example of the millions
probably billions of soil microbes that
we're really just starting to
understand
all right so i'm going to start with
soil organic matter
um we measure soil organic matter in our
lab
using loss on ignition which is really
simple
and it's the way that everyone has been
looking at soil organic matter
uh for as long as i you know i don't
think there's any other real way
to look at soil organic matter beyond
this
so basically what we do is you know you
take your soil
you weigh it and then you simply burn
off everything
that can be burned off at 500 c so this
is that living
dying dead that i was talking about
earlier
then that number can be reported as
percentage loi which some scientists use
or for your percentage of organic matter
we apply this equation
and we're able to report your percentage
organic matter
so it's very simple and it's exactly the
same way that everyone does it
all right so we also look at soil
protein in our lab
this is something that we developed
ourselves this test is commonly known
as the ace protein test also the nrcs
is calling it bioavailable nitrogen
and this is a really good way to think
about soil protein
so there's a lot of different types of
soil proteins
and protein like substances in the soil
these are typically derived from plant
residues
majorly derived from plant residues and
the way to think about this
is it's a way to get out at the amount
of bioavailable nitrogen
which is available in your organic
matter right so this is the nitrogen
that can be easily
uptaked by that um by the microbial
community and then released mineralized
for the plant uptake and you can see
here when i was talking earlier about
the dying living dead
um and i was talking about the active so
that was the um
yeah living dying section you can see
here that that includes
the soil protein
all right so then i'm just going to um
along with this talk about how we
actually measure this
in the lab um this is by far our most
complicated soil health test
uh but basically what we do is that
we extract the aggregates from the soil
using a sodium citrate buffer we then
take this solution
and we autoclave it and then we pipette
out two mils
um of this slurry which is then
centrifuged
the centrifuged slurry is then um
removed and put into these little plates
that you see here
on the screen and we're able
through adding the thermo pierced bca
protein assay it actually changes the
color
in according to how much protein is in
it and then we're able to read for this
cover with a spectrophotometric
plate reader and it's a very strong
indicator
quite a few other labs have started um
doing this
as well
all right so we also look at soil
respiration
um soil respiration i think the best way
to think about that
is as a proxy for the metabolic
activity of your soil microbial
community
all right so it's not really a way to
think about abundance of soil microbes
it's more a way to look at how active
they are
but of course if you have more it might
be more active but it might not
so i think um everyone here probably
knows
that these uh soil microbes basically
breathe out
co2 it's a part of the carbon cycle
um and this is what we're getting at and
what we're really looking at
when we're trying to look at soil
respiration so
some folks um do a one day respiration
we actually do a four day respiration um
the reason for this is that when you
first
sort of wake up the microbes and i'll
show you guys how we do that on the next
slide
um we know that there's this big burst
of activity
and that activity could then drop super
quickly or it could kind of slowly drop
or stay up around there
so we feel that if we're looking at that
respiration just for one day
we could have kind of an artificial idea
of how
active that soil is whereas if we look
over four days
we get in our opinion a more realistic
idea
of that metabolic activity
all right so for this soil what we do is
we take a known weight of air dried soil
and i should mention here that basically
all of our tests use air dried soil
um this is something that's a little bit
different from some other soil labs
and this is because we're really trying
to get at that life of the soil
so we put this soil on this little
aluminum whey boat that's got holes
poked in the middle
and we pipette in a known um amount of
water
which kind of slowly wakes those
microbes up
through um slowly wetting the soil back
up which has been air dried
we then put a little um capture
beaker in there of potassium hydroxide
commonly known as koh
and we seal the jar for four days
at the end of this four days we open up
the jar and we measure the conductivity
of that koh and from that we're able to
determine the total captured co2
and then these results are reported in
milligrams of co2
per per gram of dry wet soil
we also um look at active carbon in our
lab
this test was developed by ray weil
he is one of the leading soil scientists
in the world he wrote the nature
and properties of soils along with brady
which is kind of the bible of soil
science for all of us
and active carbon is a really great test
it's super replicable and what's really
cool about it is you can actually do
this
in the field with your client so i'll
show you on the next slide we measure
this with a pocket colorimeter
but point being you could do this in
real time in a field
and really get to show someone their
active carbon
right on the spot an active carbon is
kind of similar to the ace protein test
that i was talking about
and again that we're looking at part of
the soil organic matter
but in this case it's carbon of course
and it's the carbon that can serve
as a readily available food and energy
source for the soil microbial community
so again it's
it's very easy for them to access and
then to release
those nutrients to the plants into the
soil system
um so the way that we do this and this
is the way that everyone does active
carbon many labs do active carbon as
they should it's a great test
but we take again air dried soil a known
weight
and we add potassium per magnet
and potassium permanganate is very very
dark
purple and what's so interesting about
it is that it actually
bleaches out the more carbon that you
have
so if you recall my previous slide where
you could kind of see
um a range of colors the lighter
um the solution the higher active carbon
so it's a little bit
counterintuitive that's a very simple
test
um we basically add the potassium
permanganate we shake it for two minutes
we let it settle and then stop the
solution from changing
at this point it's bleached out the
solution
and then we read it with this pocket
colorimeter
and this is what i was talking about
with why it would be so easy to do this
in the field i know ray while does it in
the field
and we report this as parts per million
all right so i know this slides a little
bit busy and wordy
um this is our newest test so i kind of
shoved a lot more information into these
this slide in the next one than i
usually do but i want to talk about
these because it's really important
not only the carbon nitrogen ratio you
know that that's super important
but looking getting at your total carbon
and your total nitrogen is very
important it's hard to measure nitrogen
as i'm sure you guys know
partially because there's so many
different forms
so it's very valuable to understand what
your total is
so the total carbon in this case
is we're measuring the organic forms of
carbon so that's like the
organic matter that i was talking about
but we're also measuring the inorganic
forms of carbon in the soil and by this
i mean carbonates right so this is a
really important thing to
kind of keep in mind if you had a sample
from
say the tall grass prairie region which
happens to be where i do my research
there's masses of carbonates in that
soil system
so you would have to really look at your
organic matter and look at the total
carbon and kind of
keep in mind that you're also burning
off other carbonaceous materials
um and then the total
nitrogen is basically exactly what it
sounds like
is that we're getting at you know that
total number
in all of these different forms you know
there's the no3
nh4 and all these different forms were
able to get at that overall number with
this test
and the way that we measure this in our
lab
is using this um very new cutting edge
piece of equipment
that was developed by scalar so the way
that this
works is that we put a soil sample
in a little crucible which are those
glass containers you can see on top of
the slide
and then it goes on that little carousel
and then this apparatus will reach out
grab just one soil sample
and pull it in and subject it to
different
levels of heat so when we're looking at
the total
carbon um we do a complete
oxidation of that carbon to co2
at 1100 c so this is obviously extremely
extremely hot
and then we're able to measure that co2
using a non-dispersive
infrared detection um
and then this same piece of equipment
and off of that same sample
is able to determine our total nitrogen
um the total nitrogen is determined
using the dumas
methodology this has been around for a
long time
but basically what it does is it pulls
the sample in
and it converts all of the nitrogen
using oxygen to n2
this n2 is then measured by um thermo
thermal conductivity detection
and from that we're able to report your
total carbon and total nitrogen
i will add that this is a very standard
way to look at total carbon and total
nitrogen specifically
in europe where there's a lot of
interest in sequestering carbon and soil
being able to report how much carbon
you've sequested and
sequestered in soil but to my knowledge
we are the
third lab in the united states to own
one of these
um pieces of equipment they're very
expensive and specialized
all right so with that i'm going to move
into the physical indicators
um and this many of these are inherent
soil um properties with the exception of
aggregate stability
and the surface and subsurface hardness
and we'll kind of get into
what that really means
all right so this is back to aggregates
which is really how i started this talk
today
and um these pictures here are actually
from my research
in the tallgrass prairie region in
nebraska
so there are some very small
um remnant prairies that still exist
throughout the american midwest that
have never been
tilled or cultivated the only management
that they've had would be
burning and grazing and not all of them
even had that and i'm extremely
interested in
what soil was like before the advent of
industrial agriculture
so for this purpose i and for my
research
i went out and i sampled these tall
grass
prairie regions and as you might imagine
they have some of the highest soil
health scores we've ever seen in our lab
but without sampling something else
without that comparison sampling that i
really believe in so much
it's really hard to estimate how much
the soil has changed
so for that reason i also sampled
directly adjacent
active corn and soy rotation fields
so this soil that you see in the middle
of the screen here
that is the active ag land
most of these um places have never even
used cover crops because the soil is
just so good
and it's also worth mentioning that this
farmer had yields that were much higher
than
what is average for nebraska and you can
see here i think
visually easily how much modern
agriculture
if it's not done in a sustainable way
can really destroy those
aggregates and destroy that soil system
so back to the lab aggregate stability
is really um gets at how
stable those aggregates are when they
are rained upon you could also lose
aggregates through wind
there's other ways to lose aggregates
but that rain is typically something
that's really going to start to break
them apart
and the way that we do this in the lab
is through putting
this known weight of soil on these sits
now i will stop here and say that you
can see i think these three sieves that
have
very little soil on them and then the
other one that has quite a bit of soil
on it and these are actually from my
research
in nebraska and um the ones that have
very little soil
are of course the ag soil and you can
see how
fragile those aggregates are when
compared to the one that still has so
much soil there which is of course from
my remnant prairie
sites so management is a big deal
now the way that we look at aggregate
stability
um in our lab is that first we remove
any aggregates under 0.25 millimeters
um we then take the stable aggregates
which would be above 0.25 millimeters
and below
two millimeters and we
um sprinkle them on these sieves in an
even
thin layer we then weigh
that soil and then we put it in these
funnels underneath the funnel there's a
filter
that's catching um any aggregates that
are failing and going through that sieve
so we then subject it to a very extreme
um rainstorm it's about a
six inch an hour rainstorm which used to
be
really extreme this is something that we
see more and more
um also why it's so important to focus
on aggregate stability
and at the end of that time after
exactly five minutes
we pull off those sieves with the soil
and then we force any other aggregates
to fail
using water and simply the pressure of
our hand
um so then what we have remaining on the
sieve would just be
stone sand things that cannot you know
not aggregates what cannot fail
we have our original weight we have the
weight of what did fail
what did not fail and from that other
number were able to report
your percentage of aggregate stability
and i have included the equation that we
use for that
all right so we also look at soil
texture in our lab
and when soil scientists are talking
about soil texture
what we're really talking about is your
percentage of sand silt and clay
and i think that you can see here on
this textural triangle i'm not sure if
any of you have seen this before but the
way that this works
is that you work down the sides with
your percentage of silts your percentage
of clay and your percentage of sand
and from those numbers you can determine
um
your what's commonly called as your soil
texture and by that i mean
silt long silty clay loam sandy clay
loam
etc it's important to
understand that soil texture is really
an inherent
soil property and it's extremely
hard to change the main reason that
we're interested in soil texture
is that we actually will interpret your
results
differently depending on what your soil
texture is so
for instance we know that a clay is
going to have a very different
aggregate stability than a sand and that
goes through
on many of the things that we look at so
there are ways that you can improve and
work with your soil let's say you have a
real clay
soil there's things that you can do you
can plant deep rooted cover crops you
can
incorporate a lot of organic matter but
you should just understand
that it's probably going to stay a clay
it's very very very hard to change
all right so the way that we look at
this in our lab
is that we take again air dried soil
a known weight of air dried soil and we
shake it
in a sodium hexametaphosphate solution
and what this really is is just a soap
solution
kind of like dawn soap and if you
imagine how
they use dawn to clean again sorry kind
of a depressing example
but to clean oil off of you know birds
if there's an oil spill something like
that
it's the same concept in that that soap
solution helps to
separate particles from each other so
we take on the soap solution with the
soil and we shake it in a shaker for
exactly two hours
and over that time the sand silt and
clay particles
separate from each other so then what we
do
is we take that um little tube of soil
and soap solution and water
and we send it through a very fine sieve
that captures
um the fine sand and the coarser sand
but lets the silt and the clay go
through using water and i think you can
see that
in this picture here so what we have on
that sieve
is the sand captured and in the beaker
underneath
we have our silt clay and water
so i don't know if any of you remember
the stokes law
from physics but basically stokes law
has to do
with the speed that a particle is going
to fall
based on its size and that is how this
whole test
is set up so um clay
is much much much smaller than silt
so after two hours all of the silt will
settle
within this beaker and the clay is still
suspended
falling slowly within the water so then
we decant off the clay in the water
and we rinse the silt which is settled
in the bottom of the beaker into a tared
can
we also rinse the sand which into a
teared can
we dry them overnight at 105c
and from that we're able to report your
texture
so again it's similar to the ag stab in
that
you know we measure your sand we measure
your silt the other number
that's your clay um and this is a very
strong test
we call this the rapid soil texture test
because
some labs do texture analysis in a much
more
complicated and expensive way
um but we have found actually that our
texture test is almost i mean it's off
by a
you know a percentage if that um
almost as accurate as the standard test
which is like eighty dollars pretty much
any lab and this is twenty dollars in
our lab so it's a
it's an easier way to get at this
information all right
so we also look at available water
capacity
in our lab excuse me i'm gonna take some
water
all right so available water capacity is
really important and it's exactly like
what it sounds like
it's how much water your soil can hold
and we look at two points of available
water capacity
um the one point is field capacity and
the other point is permanent wilting
point
so field capacity is when your soil
is completely saturated with water
but it's not free-flowing underground
due to gravity right so this is
a completely saturated system as much
water as you that soil can possibly hold
that's called field capacity and the
other end that we look at is called
permanent wilting point
and what this means is it's when the
soil is so
incredibly dry that it's actually
sucking water out of the plants
themselves
to the point that they can't come back
from it and they die
permanent wilting point it's very
interesting to me to think about soil
pulling water
from plants and you can imagine that's a
phenomenal amount of pressure
to do something like that and then i
just wanted to include a little bit of
information
about how this available water capacity
is affected by your soil texture and in
this case i included some information
about different um sands so we can look
here and we can see
that a coarse sand holds very little
water
and that makes a lot of sense right it's
very logical and then when we move to
the other end
to a fine sandy loam we can see it holds
much much more water and this is because
of course a loamy soil
has the ability to hold that water
um it's worth mentioning that you know
organic
matter makes a big difference here also
so the more organic matter that you have
the more water you are going to be able
to hold also
i'm sure you guys have heard quite a bit
about that
all right so the way that we measure
this
in our lab is that we take um we have
these two chambers that basically
extract to these high levels of pressure
um and we use 10 kilopascals
to extract a field capacity and 1500
kilopascals
to extract a permanent wilting point and
pretty much how this works
is that it's pulling water out of these
samples
and once no more water is being pulled
out at those pressures we know it's done
so we take the soil um we put on a
ceramic plate that has a known porosity
um we then put it in the chamber when
it's
um equilibrated we move it out we weigh
it we put it in 105 c the next day we
weigh it again
and from that we can report available
water capacity
okay so we also look at this surface or
subsurface hardness i prefer to call
this
compaction and we do this
using a penetrometer so this is the only
um test that's actually done by the
farmers themselves
and the way that we do this is we have
this kind of little rod that gets pushed
into the ground
and it measures resistance in psi
so we do lend this equipment out we send
them
all over the country we can't send them
out of the country
but we send them all over the country
and then people are able to measure that
resistance
what's really important to understand
about this
is that root growth is highly limited
above 300 psi
so we're really trying to find numbers
under that a lot of this compaction
happens from traffic
on the field among other things plowing
causes a lot of compaction and then
there's also
natural causes of compaction um
just through the glaciers moving through
where i live or various issues
but it is nice to get out in the field
and find those compaction layers
it's really important for addressing
management all right and then as i
mentioned we also
do the kind of typical soil test which
is the ph
major and minor nutrients um
and i'm not going to get too into this
because it's it's pretty basic
information that we do in basically the
same way as everyone else
all right but from that i want to move
into managing
um for soil health so
it can get really confusing if you're
thinking about managing for soil health
it depends on your system
um you know it depends on what you're
growing etc
but you know i've been working with soil
health now for almost 10 years with this
lab
and i've been able to distill it down to
really
six basic concepts
all right so this is this idea of
feeding the underground herd
right which i really love this idea um
you know if you think about the fact
that soil is alive it's this living
system
there's so many different microbes it
makes sense that you need to feed those
microbes
right so some of the best ways to do
that are through
increasing organic matter you can do
this in lots of different ways
it's pretty much never going to hurt
your soil to increase your organic
matter
it's also really important to have cover
on your soil
all the time i understand this is hard
to do
but as much as you can keep your soil
covered the healthier your system will
be
and you can do this through um cover
crops and through inter-cropping and all
sorts of other methods
it's also really important to increase
your diversity
diversity is extremely important in soil
just as it is in life
we know that certain microbes are going
to live with certain plants
so the more diverse cropping system you
have
the more types of microbes that you're
going to attract and the more resilient
your system will be
overall it's also really important to
control your traffic
and to avoid driving on wet soil like
you can compact your soil a phenomenal
amount driving on it
one time when it's wet i understand we
can't all
choose when we get out in the field
that's just not how farming works
but if at all possible you should really
really avoid getting on that soil at all
if it's wet
and of course you need to reduce tillage
so
the average microbe moves about an inch
in its life
and if you're taking microbes that live
down at six inches and you're flipping
them to the top you can imagine
that that's not really going to make for
a happy microbe
all right so on these ideas i just
wanted to kind of show you some ways
that you can address this
i kind of tailored this towards the type
of audience i think i'm speaking to
today but basically you know for the
organic matter you're going to integrate
compost mulch you know what i mean you
don't want to farm naked
you can get perennials in there you can
get cover crops in there to keep that
cover
you know you can rotate these annuals
you can have diverse species selection
you know choose when to drive on your
field and keep those disturbances to a
minimum
and if you think about these really
quite simple things in a certain way
complicated in other ways
you really are going to be able to jump
start your system
all right so with that i'm bringing it
around
to and this is i'm getting close to the
end of my talk
so i was asked to tell you all in case
you want to type up any questions for me
got a couple slides left anyway but this
is our soil health
report right this is what you get um if
you send a soil
sample to our lab and in the case of
these two reports
um they were taken about 10 feet away
from each other
the one on the left has been um
intensively cultivated
it's tilled multiple times a year it has
multiple um
species of plants put on it a year and
the one
on the right hand side of the screen is
the grass
directly outside the field and our
report is set up like a traffic light
red orange you've got major issues
yellow you're kind of in the mid range
and the green means you're doing really
well
and if you look at these reports you can
see it's broken into physical biological
and chemical aspects of soil
and when you look at the one on the left
the intensive cultivation
we see that there's a lot of issues in
the physical and biological
parts of the soil but when we look at
the chemical aspects of the soil it
looks fine
and this is something we see all the
time and part of that reason
is because people have been managing for
the chemical aspects of their soil for
at least 100 years right but we hadn't
we didn't understand how to look at
these physical and biological
issues and this really shows you kind of
like big picture what we're trying to
get at here
is that if you don't you know you could
think if you just did a normal soil test
on this left-hand side
you would still not understand why your
soil was not doing well
but when we start to get into this
physical and biological
it becomes a lot more clear all right so
this is actually the front page of an
eight-page soil health report um
and the end of that report we talk about
short and long-term
management so we go through
everything that we looked at we write in
the report say what your
result was and for the sake of ease of
reading
i blew up the a soil protein index
and what i really want you guys to see
here is that we make these short and
long-term management
suggestions we do not make um
like recommendations and part of this is
because we work with so many different
types of clients from all over the world
that you there really isn't just like a
one thing
fixes all for this right so we instead
say
we hope that you can find something that
you can use out of these lists of
options in the short and long term
so the short term would be you know
something that you could do immediately
right
like adding organic matter adding some
more of a biomass
um integrating cover crops and then long
term it's going to be more like reducing
tillage you know think about rotating
maintaining your ph
things along those lines and i think
this is really important because it
shows like our respect
um to our clients and it shows that
there are a lot of different ways to get
at these
issues
all right so with that um again i wanted
to share my contact information
another one of my soil paintings here um
so if you're interested in that i've got
a website i have a whole initiative
based around soil painting and my
communication efforts trying to get more
people excited about soil
again our website and my instagram
if anyone's interested as well as my
contact email and thank you so much
oh that was great thank you so much
kirsten
we do have several questions from our
audience
can you explain what types of questions
we should be submitting with a soil test
yeah totally that's a great question so
you could be interested in like what
your management has done to the soil
right so that's kind of in the case of
my research like what is this industrial
i've been doing to you know some of the
best soil in the
country and i was able to get at that
through looking at these two different
samples
you could also you know some of our
clients will say
you know we're growing maybe they have a
huge perennial
garden and just a part of it isn't doing
well
then you would sample the part that
isn't doing well and the part that is
doing well and we would
see if we could get at what that um that
that issue is that's holding you back
that makes sense but really it could be
any question you know you could say
what's the difference between my core
and field and my soy field
or my front yard in my backyard
okay whatever but it'll give you just
that much more information
very good uh what can be done
to manage the soil to
hold more water
yeah so that's going to have a lot to do
with
incorporating organic matter
it's going to depend on what your soil
texture is
and if you have a pure sand you're not
you're not going to be able to really
build up
that um water holding capacity too much
just because of the nature of sand um
but you probably don't you probably have
something kind of in the middle in which
case you know
integrating masses of organic matter um
is really going to help you with that
also you know putting in like deep
rooted cover crops is going to help
um your roots to be able to go down
deeper and access
you know perhaps even the water table so
that's an option
um and you could also keep cover on that
soil to help it from drying out
which would also help keep that water in
the system
there's a lot of things that you could
do i probably have to look at your
specific soil type to answers
exactly okay and are some of these
techniques that you're talking about
also the same things
that would maximize carbon storage
uh yeah some of them are i mean
okay so like maximizing carbon storage
there's a lot of different ways that you
can do that
so again with like the deep rooted cover
crops that's a way to get like
carbonaceous materials down deep into
your system
um managing for healthy soil and keeping
your soil
healthy is going to help it hold the
carb in there
carbon is a cycle as i'm sure you guys
know just like nitrogen is right so it's
always going to be moving through
the system and that's healthy we want
that um
but there's definitely ways to kind of
keep it there
if that's what you're interested in and
a way to get at that would be looking at
some of our carbon measurements so
looking at that total carbon
we usually recommend that people use our
tests every three to five years
there's researchers who use it every
year don't get me wrong
um but for probably your question i
would try to look at the carbon that you
have in your soil
integrate some of these known management
strategies
um for increasing carbon and then
measure it again to see if what you're
doing is working
again it's all soil is different so
you're always going to have to
kind of apply your management towards
your soil
not all soils have the same capacity to
hold carbon
so it's going to depend okay very good
uh what's the procedure to
contact someone to borrow the
soil compaction tool
yep so we have it it's right on our
website um
there's actually let me think i think
it's
on a little side thing on the website
kind of
on the right hand side but you can
search our website too it's called a
penetrometer and there's a tab that says
borrow a penetrometer and we basically i
think that we lend them to people for
four weeks
and we ship it to you for free and then
we just ask that you know you pay to
ship it back to us
and we do that um we only really do that
if somebody's like sending in a soil
test because it goes
we're collecting information for the
soil test right obviously
if we send it to you use it for anything
you want for a month and then send it
back
okay very good uh
does commercially produced
high-temperature
compost uh contain all of the
necessary living soil
amendments
um short answer no uh
so not all compost is is created equal
right it's good to some our lab doesn't
do this but
other labs do you can send in for
compost testing
i highly recommend that if you're like
buying a bunch of compost for your
your farm or what have you you should
get a little bit from them
send it to a compost testing lab and
especially you're going to want to know
what that carbon to nitrogen
ratio is it might also be useful for you
to know
what your phosphorus levels are
sometimes compost can have especially if
it is derived from manure
extremely high phosphorus levels which
is not really dangerous for um your
what you're growing in your system but
it is really bad for the environment
um so also to that question
like there's different the microbes that
live in compost
aren't the same as the microbes that
live in healthy soil right so there's
always going to be these different
systems
um and different types of microbes and
in general you just want to have kind of
like as
much diversity and abundance of within
that microbial community as possible
so i would think about analyzing your
compost
and also analyzing your soil and then
maybe even analyzing your soil after you
add the compost and just really
make sure that it is giving you what you
think
you need i have seen problems um with
people adding too much compost
and basically what typically happens is
that there's so much carbon it actually
ties up the nitrogen
and then your um crops aren't getting
enough nitrogen to grow
so it's something to be aware of oh good
tip
uh can you recommend a resource either
book or website that can explain
many of these concepts in
a way that lay gardeners and farmers
can find more approachable
yeah yeah i understand this is this is
complicated
um so you know i'm gonna of course start
with our website and those fact sheets
that i mentioned in the beginning
so we have a two-page fact sheet for
each every one of these things that i
talked about today
that explains it in a much more simple
way
and explains the importance of texture
for instance kind of in a similar way is
how i presented this
and then it explains how we measure it
um
there's also a good book building soils
for better crops
and we also have a link for free
download
for that on our website and that was
written by harold van ness and fred
magdolf and that's like a really nice
kind of
overview of the system but to be
honest soil is incredibly complicated
and
that's just kind of how it is but that
said
i'm really happy to talk to people and
answer questions
so i get contacted you know
weekly by people who want me to like
help them understand their report
or help them interpret um you know the
nature and properties of the soils at
their property and things along those
lines
um so you know you can reach out to
people like me
or extension associates where you live
who
probably through a conversation can
really
simplify these quite complicated
concepts
very good that's that's helpful can you
give us some examples
of deep-rooted cover crops
yeah definitely okay so which is
such a fair question as i mentioned them
multiple times
so one of my favorite deep-rooted cover
crops is the daikon
um or tillage radish
and i'm sure you guys all know daikon
from eating it it's baking like japanese
cuisine
um and what's so cool about daikon
is that it breaks up compaction
um to really deep levels and
they get quite big so what you can do is
you can
and i worked with this guy who had
issues with his trees actually i think
it was like christmas trees
and we worked together and he planted
them in a circle around his trees
and indeed it broke up that compaction
and allowed his tree roots to get down
deeper into the system to access that
water
so there's other types of deep rooted
cover crops for sure um
if there's something specific you could
email me and i could try to find
something that
would work well for you if you don't
think daikon will
but what's so cool about it is that it
breaks down and it makes these channels
for the water and the nutrients to come
up and for drainage to go down so i
really recommend daikons for clay soil
um but anybody with compaction if you
can get away with it the only negative
about daikon
is that you leave it in the ground to
rot and i've heard that it smells
quite disgusting um and i know there was
like some famous
thing in new york recently where people
were complaining about it and things
like that so
that's kind of the only downside that i
know about daikon
um but if it's possible to integrate it
that would be a lovely example of a deep
rooted cover crop
uh what about deep rooted flowers or
shrubs in to put in a shady
site with clay soil yeah i think that's
a great idea
definitely and there's more and more
information out there
on these cover crops um
that have these but then also anything
deep rooted right
and that's kind of an important thing to
understand and you can find this
information out there
you know but is how far down are those
roots going to go
you know maybe if you're designing let's
say like a garden or something like that
a perennial garden
you know you could have a variety of
different types of rooted plants i know
that grasses
have a lot of there's a lot of really
nice deep rooted grasses
and that's a really great way to get
carbon deep down into the system
and to also help uh break up that
compaction a little bit
but yeah it's kind of like what i was
saying with the short and long term
management
it's you know it's like these concepts
you know so you guys have like kind of
the basics okay these are the things we
can do to improve soil health
and then it's up to you and you know i'm
happy to talk to
other like extension people to kind of
come up with a game plan
to that will work for your system
right i know a lot of you guys are like
landscapers and stuff like that so
you know that's not a hundred percent my
field so it's like you're gonna have to
you'll know more about what's deep
rooted landscaping
shrubs there are out there than me um
but
definitely anything that's going to be
like pushing down through that system
is really going to help you and um i'm
sure there's lots of options
for you guys along those lines okay
great
there are a few questions about the use
of wood chips
and also the debate about
using some kind of wood chips
or mulch versus green mulch
if you could just give us a little
on that maybe how to convince people
to use more green mulch
okay so i like wood chips i'm a fan of
wood chips
um but they have a major issue which is
that
they're you know really high in carbon
so
you can throw off your carbon to
nitrogen ratio
right and then you're tying up your
nitrogen so if you want a reason to
convince somebody not to use wood chips
that's what i would say personally
um and then say like okay with this
green mulch system
what's really cool about that is then
you're getting at um kind of like
different
levels of how quickly you could break
down
right so like if you have a green mulch
then you're gonna have more of that
living dying whereas um
you know the wood chips are more like
the dead right it's not really going to
give
that much to your soil it will break
down slowly
it will kind of give you some more um
like poor space
probably within your system but yeah i
mean if it was up to me
and i was looking at like wood chips
versus a green manure or something along
those lines i would go green manure
um just because you're adding more life
to the system
which in my opinion is going to give you
a stronger uh more resilient uh system
overall so
look at the carbon nitrogen ratio um and
that'll be how you can sell
the green manure pretty much very good
uh do you know of any programs that are
doing education on healthy soil
at the community or state level
um yeah i mean lots of people
lots of people are so like we are of
course um we're also involved with
um the new york soil health program so
with that we're looking right now
at um separating these soil health
results by
cropping system by location this is what
we're going to move into in the future
we're going to have like kind of
different results if you're in
california or if you're in new york
you would get kind of it would be
interpreted differently
um so we're working a lot on that but
there's basically people
working on soil health in every state um
most of the land grant universities are
probably working on soil health at some
level
um there's the soil health institute
that we worked with a lot that's
you know on a a global level they're
looking at soil health and they're
starting to really
um look at the different tests what's
the best and
you know get an idea of the health of
our overall country so they're doing a
lot of stuff
the nrcs is doing a lot of work with um
soil health the woman who's in charge of
that
um the director of soil health used to
be in our lab she was one of
um our grad students so of course i
think she's good and she really is she's
very smart
um but they're soil health specialists
with the nrcs in every state
they're actually hiring like big time
right now for this
um because soil health has kind of
finally been accepted by the
scientific community as being valid in
the beginning we had a lot of people
kind of
pushing back about this but at this
point i think we're past
that so yeah so look it into your nrcs
look into
um your cooperative extension look into
your land grant university
be really careful that you look um at
like what these organizations
are it's just like researching anything
i
of course i'm biased but i'm more
inclined to you know believe
a university um or the nrcs which is
part of the government
then then maybe some of these other
people who
perhaps uh aren't super well as well
trained or
perhaps as knowledgeable as some of us
who had to kind of go through a more
formal education on this
very good can you talk a little bit
about
how the use of roundup or other
chemicals
affect the microbial community or other
aspects of soil health
um yeah so
glyphosate
it's i mean it's a tricky question
there's a lot of politics tied to that
question
um it's known
that glyphosate hurts the microbial
community so
definitely like farm fields that have
had a lot of glyphosate on them
have way lower levels of microbial
diversity
and from that you could easily say that
it's probably a lot less healthy
um the way that glyphosate works is it
kind of binds up with other things
in the soil system um i think
if it's being used properly it is
probably not
um that bad of an idea but i think that
there's a lot of people that are out
there using it improperly like you can
just buy it at lowe's and you can spray
it
in your lawn i mean they are saying that
it's a carcinogen
potentially now you know it's kind of a
it's kind of a
complicated question for me to add sir
just because i want to be kind of
neutral on this subject
but basically i'll say there's times
that i think that it's appropriate
option
but in general if you're interested in
having a healthy system
i would recommend against using it um
regarding the exact microbial um
community stuff
there's a lot of people doing work on
this now
i think sort of like a lot of the things
with the microbial
community we're just scratching the
surface i'd say in another five years or
so
you know i can i could come in front of
you guys and say yes it's definitely bad
this is exactly what it does
but right now um i i think that's hard
to say
okay thank you uh in a community garden
setting some of the uh
homeowners are using no-till
and the question is how often should
they be doing
sampling to see how
the cover cropping and no-till
is comparing to surrounding plots that
are using
traditional tilling
yep so we recommend looking at your soil
every three to five years
it takes time to build up soil health it
takes time to build up organic matter
so i always recommend if you can afford
to
you should test your soil yearly for the
major
and minor nutrients ph and organic
matter
because the major and minor nutrients
and ph you may need to adjust
yearly depending on what you have going
on in your system
and then if you look at your soil health
like every single year through our lab
you'll probably see it moving but you
might even see it go backwards one year
you know oh no my active carbon is lower
than last year and then you'll call me
and you'll be all upset about it
and that's fine but it's like basically
if you give it three years or five years
then you're really gonna be able to see
big picture what's happening
um i always recommend taking like a
benchmark
establishment kind of sample before you
start managing if that's at all possible
um
but yeah no-till is really going to help
your soil i think that's one of the
fastest ways that you can
build up your soil health properties is
by cutting out the tillage
so i would expect that in three years
you could probably see a difference and
be able to report that
and say look you know i have higher
organic matter i have higher functioning
of my soil microbial community
and then you can really talk to that and
um you know
kind of expand from there okay very
very good well we are running out of
time but we've had
several questions about your fabulous
soil paintings
and i wonder if you could just spend a
few minutes telling us
a little bit about that yeah thank you
um yeah so i as i mentioned i think
briefly i have an undergrad in fine art
um i always felt and then when i
discovered soil and when i discovered
soy
science it really like fit me well and i
i loved it you know i was like okay this
is my career and i've been doing it ever
since
um but i had a really hard time kind of
understanding how i could be an artist
and a scientist
at the same time i always grew up
thinking that scientists were kind of
engineering types which i'm very much
not
um so i have a great passion for in for
encouraging creativity within science
and i do a lot of work with that
um so with the soil painting i basically
i was taking this painting class with a
an acrylic painting class with this
woman
kim's drag and i really didn't like the
colors of the acrylic paint
so i asked her if i could try to create
my own
paint from soil as i saw all these
beautiful colors of soil coming in
through the lab
um and she said i could and then i
developed my own method for making soil
paint with it
um i use this primarily as a way to get
people
interested in soil and as a
communication tool
and indeed it's really worked like that
i was just featured
in the furrow which is the john deere
magazine this summer
um i led a team to win an international
soil painting prize um contest that was
sponsored by the united nations food and
agriculture
organization i've had a couple
documentaries made about this
um so it's really taken off and it's
really
it's been really cool and really
exciting for me especially because i can
like find a way to be creative
within my position and um also it's
totally sustainable so people send us in
typically about six cups of soil
we don't really need that much um we
only need that if like one of the tests
fail you know when our qc fails then we
need to like
rerun it so typically there's extra soil
left over
which would basically just get
landfilled so
instead of it being landfilled i pull
out obviously not all of it
but i pull out cool colors and i save it
and i've got a closet in my office
filled with soil
actually um that i then can use to paint
and i do these live so i'll go
um this one i did at a reggae festival
of all things and i painted it live
um in the course of about i think it was
five hours
with this other woman actually julie
rosa who i um
brought in to help me do it and then
while i'm doing that i'm like asking
answering questions about soil and just
sort of trying to get people
excited about soil instead of formally
teaching soil science like
more like what i was doing with you guys
here today so it's just kind of a new
different way to communicate um and it's
fun i do commissions
you know i sell these i did not think
i'd ever make money with my art degree
so
that's definitely at least one good
takeaway but yeah it's fun thank you for
asking about it and i have them all on
my
and on my instagram is mostly focused on
my soil painting work
so that's fascinating
one follow-up question is are they
stable enough that you can actually hang
them and
have a lasting piece of art
yeah totally so the way that i make them
is i take
two millimeter sieve soil and i mix it
with gesso
which is gypsum um clear gesso
and water so it's kind of like i'm
making um concrete
actually and it's extremely stable
so the first series that i did
um i never even sealed them so i seal
these all with this like really high
quality
museum level varnish that just
keeps it all attached there but my the
first series that i did
i didn't seal for i don't know six years
or something like that
and they were fine um it's
i very slowly build them up so
this painting you see here on the screen
that's probably about
six layers of soil so it's like i paint
you know a layer of soil it has to dry
completely and then i come in again
so i think because of my slow building
up um
style that helps to make them more
stable and then
um the three sisters in soil which was
on my first slide
that was the one that we that we won the
big contest with that's framed under
glass
um at cornell and we actually left this
little spacer at the bottom
thinking because i didn't know i mean i
developed this i didn't know if it was
going to work or not um thinking that
maybe some soil would fall down and we
kind of set it up in a shadow box that
would hide it
and not a single piece of soil has
falled off so
um i think i do believe that it's quite
stable
oh this is this is so interesting well
thank you kirsten so much for showing
the
scientific side as well as your artistic
side
we've really enjoyed both so thank you
for sharing
thank you so much penny i really enjoyed
this and i really appreciate all of your
interest in soil health it's really it's
really important i'm always excited to
work with uh
different types of audiences on this so
again don't
don't be shy you can totally email me
and i will email you back
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu